from the gothic aesthetic and literature
such as Dracula and Frankenstein to
witches Ghouls and ghosts classic horror
movies and haunted house attractions it
has all contributed to the shaping of
Halloween as we know it today it's fun
to immerse yourself in the dark
atmosphere of the season to watch all
those great spooky movies and watch your
favorite YouTuber make content about
vampires and Halloween there is
something about the atmosphere and vibe
that just attracts a lot of people and
possibly related to this it is also like
we said an opportunity for us to
encounter and approach those darker yet
very real aspects of our lives and face
them if only for a short period of the
year